Un manuel ENTIER
de paragraphes de dissertation ?
Oui,
c’est le concept que j’ai créé
il y a quelques années.
Et ça a bien marché
— du coup,
j’en ai écrit,
des paragraphes de dissertation,
jusqu’à PLUSIEURS CENTAINES
certaines années.
Je n’ai pas compté,
mais au total,
je ne dois pas être loin
des MILLE paragraphes.
Donc j’ai un peu d’expérience
en ce qui concerne la rédaction
d’un paragraphe de dissertation...
Si vous voulez savoir
comment rédiger
un paragraphe de dissertation
PARFAIT,
vous regardez la bonne vidéo.
MAIS
avant de vous révéler ma méthode,
je veux vous rappeler
qu’il y a une chose qui est
ENCORE PLUS IMPORTANTE
que de savoir rédiger
un paragraphe.
C’est…
LA MÉTHODOLOGIE !
Eh oui,
polir vos paragraphes
ne servira à rien,
si vous ne savez PAS
faire une dissertation !
Donc inscrivez-vous
à mon cours GRATUIT
de méthodologie de la dissertation,
soit en cliquant sur le lien
qui apparaît maintenant en haut à droite
de la vidéo,
soit en cliquant sur celui
qui est dans la description de cette vidéo.
Les élèves l’adorent,
donc je sais
que vous ne serez pas déçu.
C’est un cours par e-mail,
donc regardez cette vidéo jusqu’au bout,
et puis vous pourrez découvrir ma méthodologie
après,
ou bien dans les prochains jours.
Je vous dis ça
parce que cette vidéo
est importante :
elle est importante
parce qu’elle va vous faire économiser
BEAUCOUP de temps.
En effet,
pour la plupart des élèves,
c’est LONG
de rédiger le développement
de la dissertation
— ils ne savent pas comment s’y prendre,
donc ils hésitent,
et ils PERDENT
du temps.
Mais POUR VOUS,
ça C’EST FINI,
parce qu’à la fin de cette vidéo,
vous saurez EXACTEMENT
les étapes à suivre,
et les techniques à appliquer,
pour rédiger un paragraphe PARFAIT
en dissertation.
Allez,
je vous explique
la première étape.
La PREMIÈRE ÉTAPE
de la rédaction
d’un paragraphe de dissertation,
c’est la rédaction
de l’ARGUMENT.
Un argument,
c’est une affirmation PARTICULIÈRE
présentée à l'appui d'une démonstration
— et dans le développement
de votre dissertation,
l’argument
c’est l’idée DIRECTRICE
d’un paragraphe.
C’est pour ça que c’est l’étape
LA PLUS IMPORTANTE
de la rédaction du paragraphe.
Et en plus
de présenter l’idée directrice
du paragraphe,
la première phrase est celle
qui ATTIRE L’ATTENTION
du correcteur,
parce qu’il lit
le développement de la dissertation
en diagonale.
Cette phrase est donc
CRUCIALE.
Alors,
je vais vous dire RAPIDEMENT
comment la rédiger,
parce que j’ai déjà publié une vidéo
dans laquelle je vous donne
des consignes précises pour le faire.
Vous trouverez facilement cette vidéo
sur ma chaîne :
elle commence par
« argument de dissertation ».
En résumé,
il y a SIX CHOSES IMPORTANTES
pour rédiger l’argument,
la première phrase du paragraphe.
Premièrement,
cette phrase doit être courte,
avec un seul verbe conjugué.
Ensuite,
elle doit être très claire
— il faut que le correcteur
puisse la comprendre
INSTANTANÉMENT.
Troisième chose :
vous devez affirmer l’idée de l’argument
avec NUANCE
— c’est seulement une HYPOTHÈSE
qui apporte un élément de réponse
à la problématique de la dissertation.
Quatrième chose :
la phrase ne comporte
AUCUN
type de connaissance
— ça viendra plus tard
dans le paragraphe.
En revanche,
elle doit renvoyer à la formulation du sujet
pour renforcer l’impression de pertinence
de l’argument
— ça c’est
la CINQUIÈME CHOSE.
Et enfin,
SIXIÈME CHOSE :
la phrase contient un mot de liaison
qui connecte l’idée directrice du paragraphe
à celle du précédent paragraphe.
J’en ai terminé
avec les SIX CARACTÉRISTIQUES
que doivent avoir
les premières phrases
de vos paragraphes de dissertation.
Je vous montre un exemple.
« La maîtrise des désirs reposerait
sur la sélection des influences.
»
Cette phrase fait dix mots,
donc elle est courte.
Elle est aussi claire :
elle ne comporte aucun mot technique,
et sa construction est basique.
Grâce au conditionnel
— « reposerait » —
je présente bien l’idée
comme une hypothèse.
La phrase ne comporte aucune connaissance.
C’est un paragraphe que j’avais prérédigé
pour des sujets sur le thème du DÉSIR,
donc l’argument contient
le mot « désir ».
Et enfin,
il n’y a pas de mot de liaison
parce que je ne sais pas OÙ
je vais utiliser ce paragraphe.
— si c’est le premier d’une grande partie,
je pourrai écrire simplement
« Tout d’abord,
la maîtrise des désirs reposerait
sur la sélection des influences.
».
Si l’idée directrice s’oppose
à celle du paragraphe précédent,
j’écrirai par exemple :
« La maîtrise des désirs reposerait CEPENDANT
sur la sélection des influences.
».
Ça dépend de la nature logique
de la connexion
entre les deux paragraphes.
Encore une fois,
si vous voulez des consignes PRÉCISES
pour rédiger la première phrase
d’un paragraphe du développement,
allez voir ma vidéo
dont le titre commence par
« Argument de dissertation ».
Allez,
on passe à l’étape suivante !
La DEUXIÈME ÉTAPE
de la rédaction d’un paragraphe de dissertation,
c’est LE DÉVELOPPEMENT
de l’argument.
Vous EXPLIQUEZ
l’idée directrice du paragraphe
en quelques phrases
— au moins deux,
sinon c’est trop court.
Votre objectif,
c’est simplement
d’apporter des précisions
pour CONVAINCRE le correcteur
de la PERTINENCE
de votre argument.
Du coup,
AUCUNE connaissance n’est nécessaire
à ce stade.
Regardez
comment j’ai développé l’argument
de mon paragraphe d’exemple :
« Cette hypothèse s’inscrit dans la perspective
mimétique,
selon laquelle les tendances naissent
et s’intensifient en l’individu
lorsqu’il les décèle chez ses semblables.
Il suffirait dès lors,
pour étouffer les aspirations envahissantes,
de se couper totalement de leurs sources,
afin de prévenir le trouble de l’âme
comme on reste hors d’atteinte
d’une maladie contagieuse.
En pratique,
il s’agirait de trier les occasions de la
vie sociale
en fonction des influences émotionnelles
que l’on en redoute.
»
J’explique en trois phrases
ce que je veux dire dans l’argument
par « sélection des influences » :
les hommes se contaminent émotionnellement
les uns les autres,
donc les désirs
c’est un peu comme avec une maladie contagieuse,
il faut faire attention
à ne pas fréquenter des personnes
qui peuvent nous inspirer de mauvais désirs.
La rédaction est moins soignée
que celle de la première phrase,
parce que la deuxième partie du paragraphe
est BIEN MOINS importante
que la première phrase.
Honnêtement,
on ne sait même pas
si le correcteur va lire ces phrases !
DONC vous pouvez les écrire plus rapidement.
Allez,
on passe à l’étape suivante !
La TROISIÈME ÉTAPE
de la rédaction d’un paragraphe de dissertation,
c’est l’introduction
D’UNE CONNAISSANCE.
Vous avez présenté l’idée directrice
du paragraphe,
et vous l’avez expliquée
en quelques phrases
— il est maintenant temps
de faire appel
à une autorité EXTÉRIEURE
pour renforcer la crédibilité
de votre argument.
En pratique,
vous introduisez la connaissance
en UNE SEULE PHRASE.
Cette phrase est MOINS IMPORTANTE
que la toute première du paragraphe,
mais elle est quand même importante
parce que la mobilisation du savoir
est un enjeu de la dissertation,
et aussi parce que le correcteur
va y jeter un coup d’œil.
Pour être efficace,
cette phrase doit avoir
TROIS CARACTÉRISTIQUES.
Tout d’abord,
elle indique CLAIREMENT
la connaissance que vous mobilisez.
En particulier,
si vous citez un ouvrage,
il faut souligner le titre.
DEUXIÈME CARACTÉRISTIQUE :
cette phrase doit RELIER
la connaissance
à l’idée directrice du paragraphe.
Le correcteur doit comprendre FACILEMENT
que la connaissance mobilisée
est PERTINENTE.
TROISIÈME CARACTÉRISTIQUE :
comme la première phrase du paragraphe,
celle-ci doit être plutôt courte
— c’est plus efficace,
donc plus facile à comprendre.
Voyons comment j’ai mobilisé une connaissance
dans mon paragraphe d’exemple :
« C’est ainsi une véritable quarantaine
que Sénèque préconise à son ami Lucilius.
»
Alors,
je dis en substance
que le philosophe Sénèque
a recommandé à son ami Lucilius
de se protéger des mauvaises influences.
La phrase indique CLAIREMENT
la référence
avec les noms « Sénèque »
et « Lucilius ».
Elle la relie
à l’idée directrice du paragraphe,
la sélection des influences,
avec le mot « quarantaine ».
Et enfin,
elle fait douze mots,
donc elle est plutôt courte.
Vous pouvez aussi
insérer un mot de liaison
pour connecter l’introduction de la connaissance
avec le développement de l’argument
— comme je l’ai fait
avec le connecteur logique d’illustration
AINSI —
mais vous n’êtes pas obligé,
parce que c’est souvent compliqué.
C’est tout pour cette étape.
On passe à la suivante !
La QUATRIÈME ÉTAPE
de la rédaction d’un paragraphe de dissertation,
c’est LE DÉVELOPPEMENT
de la connaissance.
Votre objectif,
c’est d’apporter des précisions
à propos de la connaissance
que vous venez d’introduire
afin de prouver au correcteur
que vous la maîtrisez
— et que vous ne faites pas
du name dropping.
Cette partie est LA MOINS IMPORTANTE
du paragraphe,
car c’est là
que vous « DÉBALLEZ »
vos connaissances.
Là,
vous devez foncer
sans vous prendre la tête.
Ce n’est pas grave
si la rédaction est moins soignée,
parce que c’est la partie
que le correcteur lira
LE MOINS ATTENTIVEMENT.
Voyons comment je m’y suis pris
dans mon paragraphe d’exemple.
Je ne vais pas lire cette partie :
mettez la vidéo en pause
si vous voulez la lire.
Pour développer la référence,
je détaille
ce que dit le philosophe Sénèque
dans sa lettre
à son ami Lucilius.
Je cite une phrase de la lettre,
et je souligne le titre du livre.
La citation,
c’est un petit plus
— ce n’est pas obligatoire.
Allez,
il reste une dernière étape !
La CINQUIÈME ÉTAPE
de la rédaction d’un paragraphe de dissertation,
c’est LE RAPPEL
de l’idée directrice.
Votre objectif,
c’est simplement de FERMER
le propos
en aidant le lecteur À MÉMORISER
l’idée importante du paragraphe.
En pratique,
contentez-vous simplement
de REFORMULER
la PREMIÈRE PHRASE
du paragraphe.
L’idéal,
c’est de lier cette phrase de conclusion
au passage qui la précède
pour soigner la fluidité du paragraphe
— mais bon,
l’idéal c’est l’idéal.
Regardons la dernière phrase
de mon paragraphe d’exemple :
« Il faudrait donc se soustraire aux mauvaises
influences
pour rester maître de ses désirs.
»
La première phrase du paragraphe,
c’était :
« La maîtrise des désirs reposerait
sur la sélection des influences.
»
Donc je dis quasiment la même chose :
je parle de soustraction
plutôt que de sélection
— mais l’idée est la même,
c’est l’idée directrice du paragraphe.
Je lie cette phrase de conclusion
à la partie précédente du paragraphe
grâce au connecteur logique de conséquence
« DONC ».
Vous connaissez maintenant
les CINQ ÉTAPES
pour rédiger un paragraphe de dissertation.
En résumé,
vous devez :
présenter l’idée directrice du paragraphe
en une phrase ;
développer cette idée
en quelques phrases ;
introduire une connaissance PERTINENTE
par rapport à l’idée directrice ;
développer cette connaissance ;
et enfin,
rappeler l’idée directrice
du paragraphe.
Tiens,
à propos de rappel,
je vous rappelle
que vous pouvez
vous inscrire à mon cours GRATUIT
de méthodologie de la dissertation,
soit en cliquant sur le lien
qui apparaît maintenant en haut à droite
de la vidéo,
soit en cliquant sur celui
qui est dans la description de cette vidéo.
Voilà voilà,
j’espère que cette vidéo vous sera utile.
Je suis Romain,
je suis toujours avec mon fidèle Haristote,
et vous étiez
sur 1000 idées de culture générale.
Rappelez-vous que vous n’avez pas besoin
de vous prendre la tête
pour rédiger un SUPER
paragraphe de dissertation.